let's go back to the word assumption and
the filter that the director sees this
story from how much does the director
really have to check their own worldview
their own worldview for the filter that
they see the world through which has
years of good things bad things traumas
abandonment happiness praise how much
did they really have to know themselves
to see am i projecting this worldview
which may not be correct on to every
story
okay couple color you know first of all
how much do they know themselves
yeah and how important first of all
really important to know themselves I'm
not it's really important to know
themselves I'm sort of struggling a
little bit with how much do they have to
check themselves but let's go back to
notice I think they really have to know
themselves a lot know who they are I
think the more you know who you are the
more you know about your assumptions
your prejudice prejudices your view of
life in the world because of your life
experiences and how you see things
through different filters the more you
know that the better director you're
going to be the the more able you may be
to get out of the way your job is to get
out of the way out of the story and not
try to impose something on a story or on
characters there's a process of the
Travis technique which I don't know if
you and I have talked about much at all
called write your life which is and it's
it's a very important part of the whole
process which is storytelling and
storytelling not so much writing even
though it's called write your life but
it's autobiographical storytelling
taking a an event in your life and
telling one event in your life maybe
only takes three four five minutes to
tell this event the question is when
you're telling an event in your life
can you tell it honestly if you're
telling something that happened to you
this is what I love about this workshop
in this way of working that event is
already written there's nothing to write
it happened this happened this happened
this happened this is the event that
happened done so there's nothing to
create what what your challenges is how
do I tell this story how do I tell this
story openly and honestly second
question is do you know yourself well
enough you are the protagonist of that
event how well do you know yourself and
how well are you willing to reveal
yourself in all your flaws and all your
courage and all your trepidations
expectations whatever was going on with
you and that event can you really do you
really understand and can you can you
reveal it in the story knowing that in
that event you're gonna tell that it's a
little 3-minute event your journey
through that three minute story is the
only thing that the story is about what
happened around you let's say was a
birthday party that you went to or
something like that some strange things
happen all those things that happened
around you and that impacted you that's
not the story the story is how you felt
how you reacted what you thought what
you were feeling what you were desiring
what you're expecting that's the story
and that's the story of any character in
any movie so going through write your
life can you even do that how well do
you know yourself and the better you
know yourself and can see how you
operate in any moment
the better you're going to be able to
see other characters the better you're
going to be able to work with actors so
this whole thing of knowing yourself is
crucial and this is why we teach write
your life to so many writers directors
and actors so that they can start from a
point of self-awareness and
self-revelation before going into
writing the next script before that
taking that next rule before directing
that next
if you know yourself you say I now
understand how I operate as a human
being you understand every character you
work with so much better so that that is
crucial and then getting back to your
question about imposing your own
worldview on it you will be less likely
to do that because you'll be more likely
to want to honor the view of the
characters and there's one other aspect
of this too is that when you read a
script and it impacts you I'm assuming
you have this script that you've read
that you want to make into a movie and
you've been really so moved by it you
say I want to make this my first
question to you the director would be
great why do you want to make this all
there but all that but what do you want
to say what do you want to do the best
answer that is I want to create this as
a movie the story as a movie so that
viewers will have the reaction I had to
it not so I can push this message on
them I was so moved by this I was so
moved by these character I was touched I
was brought to tears and laughter and I
went on an emotional journey as I was
reading this I want to afford an
audience of viewing audience the same
experience knowing that for each member
of the audience it'll be different there
won't be exactly the same as mine
you